Ma'am please put down the sword that's captain
carter the war ended almost 70 years ago
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my marvel what
if video for that avengers post credit scene the
ending teasing what's going on with captain
carter nix there's a whole bunch of multiverse
stuff that they're setting up with this ending
scene because she's gonna be crossing over with
a bunch of other multiverse characters soon so if
you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the episodes i will be doing videos for
all the episodes this season and we're doing
that disney plus giveaway for memberships all
you have to do to enter is just be a subscriber
and let me know which other big what if episodes
you want them to do in the future careful for
spoilers if you have not seen the episode yet
because we'll be talking about everything so
at the end of what if episode 1 they combined the
ending of the first captain america movie because
the whole episode was based on a different version
of the captain america movie plot but they were
combining the ending for red skull captain america
and the avengers post credit scene from that movie
in the movie steve rogers disappears from the
public for 70 years because he winds up going into
the ice red skull got teleported to vormir by the
tesseract the space stone and then captain america
is found by shield unfrozen and nick fury has to
give him the business about what he missed the
last 70 years we won the war then he recruits him
to join the avengers which he's putting together
for the first time so steve rogers captain america
became the first avenger to be born to get his
origin story earlier in the timeline but he also
became the first avenger to formally join the team
so the title of episode 1 was what if captain
carter became the first avenger but the whole
idea is that the ending of episode 1 is a little
bit bigger than what it seems like because there's
this multiverse element at play that they don't
really tell you about right away on the show
jeffrey wright's watcher uwatu specifically
mentions the multiverse when he's doing the
outro for the episode but they kind of bury the
lead in this avengers post-credits scene here but
the whole idea of the end of the episode is that
they combined the red skull captain america ending
and she disappears for 70 years but it's because
the tesseract seemingly teleports her through time
and space to the events of the very beginning
of the first avengers movie in 2012. whereas in
the avengers movie it was loki who showed up in
this scene at the other end of that portal sir
please put down the spear as he was holding the
scepter there were a lot of other things that were
different in that scene because in the original
sacred timeline version of things calling the
infinity saga the sacred timeline the way the loki
showbrunner was talking about it events played
out very differently so like you had eric selvig
here who was messing with the tesseract although
he wasn't the one who opened the portal they were
just experimenting on it and it just mysteriously
opened a portal so because events played out
a little bit differently in captain carter's
universe that's why you're not seeing eric selvik
here in present-day like there are other minor
differences obviously they don't get into because
it's just meant to be this wtf scene like wait a
minute 70 years later what happened but then the
watcher gives his outro speech about how captain
carter's one little choice at the beginning of
the episode gave birth to a new hero for the
multiverse and he's very careful to say multiverse
that gets into future episodes in the scenes
where you see her crossing over with the other
multiverse versions of the avengers the guardians
of the multiverses they're calling them but at
least right here in this avengers scene nick
fury then would recruit her to this universe's
version of the avengers which pays off the whole
title of the episode what if captain carter
became the first avenger now we know hawkeye
is there he's being played by jeremy renner on the
show presumably there are versions of most of the
other original avengers in this universe when i
said that they kind of buried the lead with this
avengers wtf scene here uwatu calls her a new hero
of the multiverse because this version of captain
carter will be the version who joins the watchers
guardians of the multiverse team and show up in
future seasons whereas not every single character
that we see during what if season 1 is going to
come back during season 2. but this is also why
in that previous trailer the watcher is narrating
about time and space not being a linear path he
also says that at the beginning of the episode
when they do their version of the loki scene with
the sacred timeline splitting off into alternate
timelines alternate realities it sounds like
they're using captain carter's nexus event here
as the point of origin for the what if series
and her actions leading to the creation of all
these other branch timelines alternate realities
that we'll visit during the next several episodes
you have to imagine during the loki finale that
when we're looking at the sacred timeline here
bursting with the branching timelines one of these
major branches represents the what if episodes
starting with captain carter peggy carter in all
the future episodes of what if are the smaller
branches coming off of that major branch so really
the more accurate title for what if episode 1
would be what if captain carter were the first
guardian of the multiverse although not literally
because the true guardian of the multiverse
in the cosmic sense is the living tribunal
we'll see how cosmic they get with the marvel lore
everyone was asking them are you gonna do x-men
are you gonna do fantastic four are you gonna do
deadpool the only thing the showrunners said is
that they weren't allowed to do characters that
marvel had not introduced yet in the movies which
includes the brand new x-men characters deadpool
has not shown up in the mcu yet even though
deadpool just did that big korg crossover which is
technically him inside the mcu ryan reynolds said
that disney had to approve that like they had to
go through this big approvals process technically
it doesn't count for the purposes of what they're
doing with the marvel disney plus stuff and they
haven't officially done the living tribunal in
the mcu movies or the disney plus series yet you
may remember a couple years ago after avengers end
game came out that the writers did say there was a
deleted scene of the living tribunal that almost
made it into avengers infinity war if you don't
remember there was this cool comic-con panel that
the writers of avengers infinity war and avengers
end game did after the movies came out where they
explained this massive road map of stories ideas
things that they compiled while they were planning
both of the movies in one of the biggest cosmic
scenes that didn't make the final cut was that
during the battle on titan when doctor strange
the avengers the guardians of the galaxy were all
fighting thanos one of dr strange's boss level
moves was to send thanos on a fantastic voyage of
the multiverse the same way the ancient one did
for him in the doctor strange movie and at the end
of that he was going to take thanos to be judged
by the living tribunal for crimes against the
universe but that was just a little too extra for
the movie because it was already a huge movie it
just required too much extra dialogue to explain
for people who were not comic book readers and who
had no idea who the living tribunal was so like
okay you know we'll just cut this out we'll save
this for some future movie to take care of the
funny thing about that is that that future movie
wound up being the loki series during loki episode
5 you see the head of a statue that represents the
living tribunal that doesn't mean that this was
actually the living tri-beetle it just means that
it was a statue representing the living tribunal
the other really big question that i saw a lot of
people asking after episode one in this avengers
scene was how captain carter wound up time
traveling here to the events of the avengers movie
like how did she time travel if the space stone
is only supposed to teleport you through space
not time i think there are three basic ways you
could explain this one the showrunners could just
be playing it fast and loose with the powers of
the space stone saying that it can open portals
through time and space not just space two they
could be using the idea of time dilation in the
way the tesseract portals work like through the
process of her traveling in this particular portal
moments might pass for her but in normal space
time time passes much more quickly and she just
lost 70 years in transit but for her it only
felt like a few seconds and three this is less
likely but they could be secretly saying that the
tesseract portal opened a wormhole into another
universe and in that alternate universe that she
traveled to it was just moving at a different pace
different part of the timeline but at least
right now without the showrunners explaining
more my assumption is that it's a combination
of one and three like the showrunners are just
playing it a little fast and loose with how things
work because the episodes are only 30 minutes long
and they need to speedrun a lot of this plot they
need things to spin up into the multiverse stories
really really fast there were a lot of comments
about that after episode one as well like wow they
really blew over a lot of these big plot points
the only reason why it seemed like it was so
easy for her to become a super soldier and do
all those things is just because the episode
was so short and they needed to get to this
avenger scene moment at the end of the episode
under normal circumstances like you would just
do a show about captain carter and you would
spend the entire nine episodes dealing with her
becoming a super soldier whereas here they did it
in 30 minutes but at least for the first couple
of episodes the way the show treats things it's
as if these different main characters that you see
in the trailer all come from alternate universes
in the way the multiverse loki style explainer
works it all flows from captain carter's nexus
event like she takes a different path and it leads
to all these other branch realities coming off of
it these other timelines where you see the other
characters showing up i believe it's not till
around episode three that they really start to
get into the bigger questions and crossover stuff
which is actually about how they paced out the one
division episodes one division was a series that
also had nine episodes like what if and it really
was until episodes three and four that they really
started explaining things and they started to go
off the rails revealing what was really going on
inside the hex whereas the first couple of
episodes were just more of a twilight zone
situation where you're like everything is weird
what's going on we have no idea is this mephisto
so no mephisto is not the main villain of what if
for the most part i believe they're just pitching
final boss form ultron with the infinity stones
in vision's body is the bigger villain of season
one right now at least the biggest villain that
we know about there is technically all the kang
the conqueror stuff and the kang variants that
are happening right now they're really meant to
be the big marvel phase 4 thanos level threat
but i don't think the kang is supposed to show
up anywhere during the what if series for those
of you asking though the reason why kang is a
bigger threat than ultron with all six infinity
stones and vision's body is because using eliath
kang can consume multiple timelines many alternate
realities instantly in for example someone with
the infinity gauntlet can change anything they
want in a single universe with the snap of their
fingers but the infinity gauntlet only works in
the universe that those infinity stones came from
that's one of the reasons why on loki the
infinity stones are sitting in a drawer because
most of them come from a bunch of alternate
timelines alternate realities does anyone need
an extra paperweight so this version of ultron on
what if could not wipe out a bunch of alternate
timelines over here on the other end of the sacred
timeline he could only affect his own timeline a
version of kang could take goliath and just chow
down this entire larger branch of the multiverse
this major branch and with it many many smaller
alternate realities all at the same time so he's
a much much bigger threat he who controls eliath
controls the multiverse that should also be one
of the big takeaways from the loki finale but if
you have any other questions about what's going on
with what if just leave them in the comments below
i'll do a what if episode 2 trailer video tomorrow
there's so much stuff that just happened so many
videos that i'm working on right now so i'll try
to get those all out as quickly as possible it is
going to be a real awesome summer congratulations
cat jab you're the giveaway winner from my last
big what if episode video please email me on the
about page of my channel so i can get your contact
details everyone click here for my full what if
episode 1 video and click here to learn what's
going on with thanos during the what if series
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video!